through his school Gates had covered the
teenage boy suspected of killing his
classmates is Led away
at this prestigious Primary in central
Belgrade a model pupil armed with a gun
and a list of targets is accused of
opening fire
at least eight children and a security
guard would be dead by the time the 13
year old stopped shooting
I was able to hear the shooting it was
non-stop it was not like one shot at a
time it was shooting without stopping I
didn't know what was happening we were
receiving some messages on the phone
as terrified parents LED their children
to safety the horror of what happened
here has been overwhelming
police say the boy named KK arrived in
the morning with his dad's gun and four
Molotov cocktails he shot the teacher
and his classmates then called the
police to confess
my child survived this you can't imagine
she saw a man falling down shooting she
was running away she thought the boy
with the gun would run after her it was
hard mass shootings in Serbia are rare
the last was a decade ago
police believe this latest attack was
carefully planned they found a handful
map of the school
s
the sketch looks a bit like something
from a video game or a horror movie
which indicates that he's planned in
great detail how to enter which
classroom
and how to execute each child
several of the injured are still in
hospital two in a critical condition
three days of mourning have been
announced to remember the victims
innocent lives allegedly lost at the
hands of a child too young to be held
criminally responsible Siobhan Robbins
Sky News